so what I want to do here is have a
discussion on one punch man and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of this video
you'll have a strong understanding of
why he's so popular as well as some of
the anime tropes that went into the
development of his character
however as begin to this something I
want to do is shift our initial focus to
Japanese culture and the history of
anime and manga as a whole so in truth
the concept of manga has its roots in
both pre World War two and post World
War two Japanese culture what I mean
here is that historically artistic
renderings within Japanese society date
back as early as forty thousand years
before Common Era during the Mesolithic
jamun period which most of these
paintings depicting the view of the
world through the eyes of these
primitive societies focusing more on
nature rather than people itself however
with the advent of organized religions
like Buddhism the rise of the early
ruling dynasties and the varying levels
of exploration these primitive
illustrations of nature gave way to a
combination of social and governmental
critiques depictions of wartime conflict
and religious themes all of which were
reflected in differing styles of art
ranging from the Yayoi high on and Ito
periods furthermore during the Meiji era
between 1868 and 1912 which saw Japan
moving away from being an isolated
feudal society and toward its modern
form Japanese society began to gain more
and more exposure to the political
cartoons of France and England meaning
that during this time the concept of
manga came into existence as a series of
short stories where these various forms
of manga could be used as what the means
of storytelling as well as a financial
bargaining chip among those societies
looking to barter knowledge of Japan's
reclusive nature because manga proved to
be so popular it became an influential
part of Japanese society allowing for
more complete stories that involve both
words and pictures allowing for
depictions of historical heroes and
combat or exercising religious actions
conversely while pre-world War two Japan
was still relatively isolated following
the conclusion of world war ii and the
signing of the japanese instrument of
surrender on the USS missouri a
condition of the treaty and subsequent
u.s. censorship policies which Japan
would not be allowed to glorify war or
its military this combined with article
29 of the Democratic Japanese
Constitution which established further
censorship on the varying forms of media
made that artists and creators in
Japanese society had to find more
creative ways to express their art
without running into legal issues
to this end the first modern day mongers
are believed to have appeared in April
of 1946 and 1952 with Michiko Hasegawa
Stasi son and Osamu Tezuka's futuristic
story mighty Adam respectively finding
its inspiration in the advent of
American superheroes from the Golden Age
mighty Adam combined elements of
American comics with Japanese themes and
centered on a young Android named Astro
Boy finding his place in the world by
fighting crime and injustice at the same
time saws ice on did not contain
superhero themes and instead focused on
the title character being a liberated
woman focusing heavily on feminist
themes and her struggle with societal
views of expanding women's rights
because he stories proved to be so
popular among both men and women
following the release between 1952 and
1969 a surge of manga appeared in
Japanese pop culture coming in two forms
Shonen manga which was aimed at
adolescent and pre-adolescent voice and
shoujo manga aimed at adolescent and
pre-adolescent girls now during this
renaissance of manga anime also found
its foothold in Japanese society as a
source of entertainment designed for
audiences of all ages
rather than Western forms of animation
which are primarily geared towards
children where the art forms that led to
the advent of modern manga date back
thousands of years the precursor to
anime came as a branch off of
traditional forms of art involving the
idea of pictures moving and sequence and
telling a story where these early forms
of animation were ad hoc and that the
pictures were specifically arranged to
tell a particular story which was
narrated by a presenter and accompanied
by music during the Great Depression of
the 1920s which originated in the United
States but affected global economies men
from across varying professions were
left without work turning to multiple
forms of employment to make ends meet as
such these early forms of animation
became heavily popular as a source of
income a because competition was so
stiff due to the high unemployment rate
much like the consequence of censorship
and manga in the 1950s and 60s I was
looking to find a niche for themselves
in the fledgling anime community were
forced to evolve the genre in an effort
to stay viable to this end between 1928
going into the mid 1930s primitive forms
of animation began to surface involving
differing views of traditional Japanese
culture and modern Japanese culture
however the problem faced by these
creators was at Disney was on the
upswing with their various short films
like Steamboat Willie
meaning that Disney was already
producing quality animation while
Japanese animators were
only then getting into the industry
furthermore the artistic choice of these
traders was virtually stamped out during
the 1930s leading into World War two
when Japan's Imperial Government began
to shift its focus from allowing free
expression of creativity to censoring
all forms of media that did not coincide
with the idea of Japanese nationalist
views because a nation was swept with a
myriad of propaganda following Germany's
invasion of Poland in 1939 and the
official start of World War two when the
war began these various animators found
themselves employed by the state with a
nearly unlimited budget what this meant
was that when they were unable to create
stories of their own design it did grant
them the opportunity to hone their
skills and expand the animation market
within Japan itself meaning that when
the war ended anime saw an uptick in
popularity around the same time as manga
in the 1950s and 1960s as an example in
1958 the first full-color animated
feature film was titled Haku jhaddon or
the tale of the white serpent and was
produced by Toei animation because
Disney had already established itself as
a premiere animation studio with Snow
White in 1937 Toey animation modeled
Haku jhaddon after Disney themes with
the inclusion of musical numbers and
animal sidekicks or this continued to be
the trend for the next several years
in 1963 the Astro Boy manga was adopted
to an animated feature by combining the
successful themes of the manga with a
form of animation that differs from
Western styles Astro Boy crater Osamu
Tezuka effectively created a template
for modern-day anime with the inclusion
of sophisticated cinematic effects like
panning shots to create background
motion as well as shifting visual
focuses from background to foreground
and so with Astro Boy proven to be a
massive success in the Japanese
community various other Studios began to
use the same process which led to the
introduction of shows like 1986 is
Dragon Ball 1988 iconic film Ikeda by
katsu hero automa and 1992 Sailor Moon
furthermore because animes did not use
real-world actors for the viewer
there was no conflicting reality and
that if the character died in the anime
fans could not point to another film
with a character appeared instead the
character was dead and remained dead
unless the core plot of the story saw
the resurrection by mystical or
religious themes as such with the core
of anime focusing on the story and
character development viewers found
themselves immersed in the intensity and
emotional form of the TV show or the
film
now having said all of that in October
2015 interview with my anime list one
punch man creator one had stated that
the influence for this series came out
of the hard-hitting and fast-paced
nature of shows like Dragon Ball Z in
the Ruto because these shows centered on
over-the-top fight scenes involving
characters with insane amounts of power
their popularity led to a series of
tropes poking fun of the nature of these
shows their impossibly powerful heroes
and intense characters looking to create
a story that offset these tropes by
acting as a parody one punch man
quite literally serves as the Deadpool
of the anime world and then while he
doesn't have a dark humor his popularity
is rooted in the idea of traditional
animes taking themselves too seriously
to this end one punch man was released
in 2009 as a webseries and in its
original creation was actually mediocre
regarding its art however because most
manga fans prefer a mediocre art with
good storytelling to good art with
mediocre storytelling this series proved
to be popular among enter manga groups
now having said that what I want to do
here is take things a bit out of
continuity and actually jump to issue
number 2 of the series which focuses on
the origin of one punch man leading into
his first battle with the second issue
titled crab and job hunting the story
takes place three years prior to the
first issue and establishes the basis of
how Saitama became one punch man opening
up with Saitama encountering a giant
crab man the indication is a Saitama
should be fearful for his life due to
the appearance of this individual in
addition to this we're told that this
monster is named crowd Lotte who was
formerly a normal human transformed into
his current state by eating too much
crab now again this is really just
designed to be nonsensical and poke fun
at the origins of villains who find
their bases in over-the-top histories or
mutations as an example in Dragon Ball Z
there were various characters named
after foods including sorbet vegetables
and broccoli furthermore it's also
revealed the Saitama himself is actually
unemployed and looking for a new job
which is put him in the mindset and that
he doesn't really care about what's
going on now to focus on this for second
and Western culture a kind of metric
system exists regarding work ethic and
that people are measured from
hard-working to lazy with most
individuals falling somewhere in between
however Japanese culture instills a more
comprehensive view of work comprised of
respect pride and honor
meaning that those men who are without
are deemed is disrespecting the heritage
of their families now transitioning back
to the story where Carlotta agrees to
its name's transitioning back to
the story or Crabb want a agrees to let
Saitama go due to the fact that he's
essentially a lifeless man with no
purpose of life Rob Lotte also states
that his intention is to track down and
kill a young brat with a cleft in his
chin from here the story begins to go
from funny to funnier when we learned
that rather than the cleft being
proportional to the shape of the child
instead but the cleft is massive and
actually looks like a set of butt cheeks
on the front of his face what we also
learned here is that the reason why I
called its names what we also
learn here is that the reason why crab
latte is going after this child is due
to the fact that while crab latte was
sleeping in the park that you the child
your nipples on and with a marker now to
be honest here in my personal opinion if
someone drew if someone falls asleep in
public with their shirt off nipple
drawing is perfectly acceptable but only
if the person was a jerk because crab
allanté is a giant crab monster we can
probably get away with saying that he
was a bit of a dick and likely deserve
to be drawn on but regardless despite
the fact that this story is designed to
be a little silly one does not forget
about developing Saitama as a character
if regarding the hero's journey because
the first part of this process involves
a call to adventure this comes in the
inner struggle of determining whether or
not he should intervene and allow the
child to die I like him to save the
child and his chin slide Saitama steps
in taking the child to safety at the
same time the crab latte launches his
attack on the boy at this point the
second stage of the hero's journey comes
into play we cite how much initial
refusal to accept what a visit he's
doing and even questioning whether his
actions are right continuing to work to
save the child while the boy tries to
travel back in grab a soccer ball
Saitama attempts to reason with crab
latte and asking whether or not it's
worth it to kill a young boy over such a
simple prank
however for crab latte the insult
engendered by the child went beyond
anything that could be rationalized and
involved disgracing crab latte on a
personal level by giving him nipples
where he previously didn't have any now
one of the reasons I enjoyed this part
of the story so much was because this
was literally a monster losing its mind
and freaking out
about having nipples drawn on it this
particular bid is actually designed to
parody the intensity of most animes and
mangas regarding the over top emotions
are their characters regarded they're
screaming and they're shouting but from
here
Saitama draws the attention of crab
latte by poking fun at him a bit in
saying that crab want a reminds him of
the villain that he knew from an anime
that he used to watch now on its face
where this seems to be a little
nonsensical the greater goal of Saitama
is at eight crab lattes attention away
from the child and focus it on himself
what's also interesting here is that
we're heroes normally undergo the
process of intense training with some
kind of master of mysticism or martial
arts Saitama doesn't do any of that
instead we're told that ever since he
was a child he had dreamed of being a
superhero who defeat his villains with
one punch drawing on that desire here
Saitama simply becomes one punch man by
force of will resulting in the defeat of
crab latte with a single hit to the face
knocking one of his eyes out in the
process now following the first two
issues of one punch man as it was drawn
and released by one between 2009 and
2012 the series received over 7 million
hits proving itself to be highly popular
among the manga community as a result
one punch man was inducted onto the
roster of titles featured on the young
jump website an online counterpart to
the weekly young jump magazine released
by Shueisha publishing company which has
been running since 1979
featuring various forms of manga geared
towards adolescent boys with renowned
manga artists Yusuke Murata taking over
the artists duties the series
immediately went viral garnering over
20,000 hits per day on the young jump
web comic site with 10 million total
views between April 2012 and January of
2013 as a result of its popularity one
punch man began syndication with weekly
shonen jump under viz media which
focused on manga geared towards teenage
boys this combined with a series being
translated to English for non Japanese
speaking cultures meant that the viewer
base expanded even further leading to
one punch man quite literally becoming a
staple of both pop culture and manga as
a whole as a result on April 4 2015 the
series was adapted to an animated form
and circulated by madhouse an animation
studio based out of Tokyo Japan which
syndicated this series across a
multitude of mediums including local
Japanese television stations as well as
international websites like Hulu while
providing subtitles for non Japanese
speaking cultures
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and you guys
won't know this by the time this video
actually comes out but it was so
difficult to record this because the
names because I don't speak Japanese but
let me know down in the comment section
whether or not you guys enjoy one punch
man and I will catch you all later peace